[Musique]
et
je peux quatre fois plus faire il faut
être une start up ou une entreprise
innovante il faut être implantées sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
et quoi avoir un produit une solution à
services
innovants
prêts à être commercialisés ou déjà en
phase de commercialisation
[Musique]
on me laisse porter pour les entreprises
demandent de participer à ce concours
d'être sélectionné d'une part c'est
d'avoir de la visibilité bénéficier de
sa visité deuxième intérêt c'est
participer gratuitement à cet événement
c'est plus de 15000 rendez vous sur
cette journée donc c'est une formidable
vitrine est une formidable opportunité
de créer des contacts
[Musique]
et